this is how I plan to retire when we
moved to Brazil shake you trying to
smoke that but no but you want to start
it how would [ __ ] crazy I'm in done
let's go let's go
well I just sold his car so let's take
care of it if you sell your car how are
we supposed to get to rock the bells
today you're not going to a concert
we're going to the concert grow up - VIP
takes 300 would you pay me $300 if I'm
sexual favors on your body
kill one yo call me about tickets your
last two I got man fine let's go oh well
okay okay we get a dumpy homophobic
what happened man no I stole two tickets
and some room rocks from some guy in
crisis are you gonna go to the concert
later you were hit on the drug dealers
girlfriend I saw this in a movie once
what happened after he is killed by a
boyfriend fingers crossed it works out
better for you
only 2% of people who get stuck up in
robberies actually get shot that's your
word
brazilian is my favorite porn search
word before drunk and amateur yeah I
don't know what it is about amateur but
I like it a lot I think it's just more
authentic they can be gonna sell me
something do it within ten hundred
percent
you